so now we're going to talk about the
concepts of validity and satisfiability
which take on some extra interest in the
context of predicate calculus so let's
remember for propositional validity if
you have a propositional formula with
variables taking the truth values
ranging over true and false then a
formula is valid when it's true for all
possible truth values so here's an
example that P implies Q or Q implies P
and you can check that for the four
possible environments of P and Q values
true false values of P and Q this or
will come out to be true well for
predicate formulas there's a bunch of
things that I need to give value to that
are more complicated than just truth
values in particular I will say that a
predicate calculus formula is valid when
it's true for all possible domains of
discourse that the variables range over
is it a technicality that it has to be
non-empty but aside from that all
possible domains and whenever you have a
predicate mentioned in the formula um in
order to know whether the formula is
true or not I need to know what that
predicate means so a formula is valid if
it comes out true no matter what the
predicate means let's look at a concrete
example to get a grip on this here is a
valid formula of predicate calculus
it's mentioning a predicate Spee and Q
it's of the form of a proposition
because it's saying something about
every possible Z in the domain and every
possible X and every possible Y the only
thing that we need to know to make sense
out of this formula to figure out
whether or not it's true is what's the
domain that XY and Z range over and what
exactly do P and Q mean well I want to
argue informally let's just look at what
this is saying together
what this is saying is suppose that for
everything in the domain both property
P of Z and P of Q in other words
everything in the domain have property P
and property Q well that certainly
implies that everything in the domain
has property P because they have both
properties and also everything in the
domain has property Q because everything
has both properties so when you say it
that way the the sense that this is a
fundamental logical fact that doesn't
depend on what P and Q mean or what the
domain is it's just a fact about the
nature of the meaning of the fur all
Universal quantifier and the connectives
and it implies that's how we figure out
that this is valid well let me go one
level in more detail to say again what I
just said informally and try to be a
little bit more precise and clearer
about a reason why this formula is valid
so suppose I wanted to prove that the
formula is valid well it's an
implication so the proof strategy there
it is written again the proof strategy
is I'm going to assume that the if part
the left-hand side of the implies or
hypothesis is true that is that for
every Z P of Z holds and Q of Z holds
and then I'm going to try to prove based
on that that the consequent holds namely
that the right-hand side for all X P of
X and for all Y Q of Y holds okay how am
I going to do that well so here's the
formula written just to fit on the line
with the concise mathematical symbols
the upside-down V means and and the
arrow means implies and we want to try
to prove that this is validity that this
is valid a little bit more carefully
well the strategy as I said is to assume
that the left hand side holds well
what's the left hand side say and says
that for every Z Q of Z holds and P of Z
holds that means that for every possible
environment that assigns a value to Z Q
of Z and P of Z both come out to be true
well suppose that the value that the
environment assigns the value C to Z
where C is
some element to the domain then what
this means is that in that environment Q
of Z and P of Z is true which means that
Q of C and P of C holds but Q of C holds
so Q of C certainly hookey and P of CL
so q FC certainly holds all by itself
all right so now we're in an interesting
situation because we just proved that
our Q of C holds and we know nothing and
have assumed nothing about C except that
it's an element to the domain C could
have been any element to the domain and
we've managed to prove that Q of C whole
so it follows that in fact we have
really proved that for every X Q of X
holds now that step of saying I proved
it for Q of a given element without
making any assumptions about the given
element except that it's in the domain
and therefore I can conclude that it
holds for all domain elements it's very
natural and plausible and understandable
rule and it's a basic axiom of logic
called ug universal generalization come
back to it in a minute anyway
I've just proved that for all X Q of X
holds and by a completely symmetric
argument for all Y P of Y holds and
having proved both for all X Q of X and
for all Y P of Y clearly the hand holds
and I've just proved that the right-hand
side of this implication is true given
that the left hand side is true now
having called this proving validity you
let me immediately clarify that this is
not fair to call a proof because the
rules of the game are really murky here
this theorem you could say that it
didn't know you could read it as saying
that Universal quantification
distributes over and is one of these
basic valid formulas that is so
fundamental and intelligible that it's
hard to see what more basic things you
are allowed to assume when you're
proving it and this proof really isn't
anything more than translating upside
down a and and the and symbol into
English and saying that I'm using
ordinary intuitive rules of
for all and and and using that in the
proof so this is a good way to think
about the formula to get an
understanding of it but it's not right
to say that it's a proof because we
haven't been exactly clear about what
the proof rules are and with this kind
of really fundamental valid fact it
becomes a quite technical problem to
decide what's what a proof is going to
be what are what's fair to assume in
what's fair not to assume it would
actually be perfectly plausible to take
this as an axiom and then prove other
things as a consequence of it anyway
going on let's look at this just for
cultural reasons we're never gonna
actually ask you to do anything with it
but the universal generalization rule ug
is would be stated this way as a
deduction rule in logic the stuff over
the bar means if you've proved this then
you can conclude that you've proved the
stuff below the bar so what this is
saying is if you've proved P of say P of
C for a constant C then you can prove
that you can deduce that for every X P
of X holds and this is providing that C
does not occur in any other part of the
predicate P except that where you're
talking explicitly about it it's hard to
be more precise about that for now and
don't worry about it
but the idea is you're not supposed to
assume anything about C other than it's
in the domain and that it has property P
and you can then conclude that
everything has property P so let's look
at a similar example where it is
possible to prove something namely I can
prove that something's not valid so
here's a similar looking formula this
one says that for every Z if P of Z
holds or Q of Z holds then for every X P
of X holds or for every Y Q of Y holds
and this one we're going to show is not
valid let's think about for a minute
what it's saying is if everything has
either property P or property
that implies that everything has
property P or everything has property q
well when you say it that way is clearly
not the case but let's go one level more
precise and lay that out what I'm going
to do is convince you that it's not
valid by giving you a counter model
where I make I chose an interpretation I
choose a domain of discourse and
predicates that Q and that P and Q are
going to mean over that domain and that
make the left-hand side of this
implication true and then I'm going to
show you that the right-hand side is not
true and that means that in that domain
with those interpretations of P and Q
this implication fails so it's not valid
so I need to make the left-hand side
true and the right-hand side false well
I'm gonna choose the domain of discourse
to be the simplest one that will make
this false namely let's let it the
domain of discourse just be the numbers
1 and 2 and let Q of Z be the predicate
that says Z is 1 and P of Z be the
predicate that says Z is 2 well is the
left-hand side true yeah because the
only things there are in the domain are
1 and 2 and so clearly everything in the
domain is either 1 or 2 so the
antecedent is true on the other hand is
everything in the domain does it satisfy
P is everything in the domain equal to 2
no one's not equal to 2 what about is
everything in the domain equal to 1 is
is it true that for all Y Q of Y holds
no 2 is in the domain and it's not equal
to 1 and so we have found exactly what
we wanted a counter model which makes
the left-hand side of the implies true
and the right-hand side of the implies
false
Glenny close with just one more example
of a valid formula that we can talk
through this is the version of de
Morgan's law that works for quantifiers
remember the
Morgan's law was the thing that said
that the negation of P or Q was the same
as not P and not Q and remembering that
the connection between Universal
quantification and-and-and existential
quantification and or it turns out that
by the same kind of reasoning de
Morgan's law comes out this way it says
that if it's not true that everything
has property P that's possible if and
only if there's something that doesn't
have property P and so that's what de
Morgan's law is it's another thing you
could take as an axiom or you could try
one of these hand waving proofs about
but I think I've said enough to give you
that example of another interesting
valid formula and we'll stop with that